And I want to get almost to the end of
my lecture by introducing you to some
things called talking balloons.
I don't know whether you've seen them before or
heard about them. This is a perfectly
ordinary balloon but attached to it is a
little piece of plastic and on the
surface of the plastic are some grooves
and if I run my fingers along them, those
grooves will make the balloon vibrate.
The grooves have been chosen so that
they will make the balloon actually speak.
It will actually say a little
phrase and so I'm going to make it say a
phrase which I don't think you'll
understand. Well, we'll see.
[sounds like incomprehensible speech]
You could hear it say something couldn't you?
Could you tell what it said?
Very difficult isn't it?
Ok well now what I'm going to
do is I'm going to program you
I'm going to tell you what it said and I think if I now do
it again you will in fact understand
what it said. What it said was "You're the greatest".
[LAUGHTER]
Now you see you're programmed and if
I came back and did this any time in the
next 10 days you would understand it.
And so you're a different audience from the
one that came in! I hope you don't mind.
Here's another one let's see if you can
understand this one.
I did that a little too fast I'll do it again.
Did you understand that one?
Yes, it said "happy birthday". We'll do it again
and you will all hear it I think this time.
Well, that really demonstrates a very
important principle in the human mind.
It illustrates the point that we are all
the time being programmed.
Every minute of our lives we are being programmed by the sounds around us. This is how babies
learn to speak, they're surrounded by
people talking, long before they can ever
talk themselves and so long before
they're producing the sound they're
being programmed and this is why a baby
will tend to talk with the same accent
as the people around it. You could have a
baby who was born in one particular
culture but immediately surrounded by
people of another and it will tend to
talk like the people surrounding it.